always great to see Dan Marino catch up
with him Monday after the Super Bowl one
of the largest diet decision days for
men and Nutrisystem is there to help you
Daniel talked about Nutrisystem coming
up in a moment we were just talking
about when people talk about how far
they can throw a football you know
there's that great scene in Napoleon
Dynamite where you know you guys go the
footage at uncle Rico Orica yeah and he
can throw it you know over the mountain
there you probably ran into people that
had stronger arms or could threw it
farther than you they just couldn't hit
anything that after that right got a hit
which is wrong right but yeah there's
always there's always Valley especially
on your team like I talked earlier about
okay McDuffie a wide I see my receiver
play I mean he can throw like 85 yards
and I could never in my life throw it 85
yards but you know he was a receiver
he's not a quarterback but that does
that at your best though my best are
probably 72 yeah 75 maybe but how many
times in your career do you think you
actually threw it that far very few very
few times usually I mean if here's one
of a long ways you know the furthest
you'll throw it is 50 55 60 yards but
has the game changed now if you were
coming out now going into the pros what
what would your style be or would it be
any different at all I don't think it
would be any different at all I mean you
know when I was younger I know people
don't remember this but actually could
move around a little bit you know make
some plays you know outside of the
pocket but I don't think my style would
be any different whatsoever I mean I
pretty much everybody you know all the
great players of that position their
style would probably be the same what do
you like certain players people play
alive is that is that the way of
complimenting you that you have some
mobility like Tom Brady will keep it
alive Ben is like you know Godzilla
where he's sticking on yeah he breaks
tackles in the pocket moves around takes
hit Tom keeps alive by moving in the
pocket you know where I still has a
vision downfield they'll just make take
one step one way or the other make guys
miss we still keeps the play line can
Tom Brady play five more years I don't I
don't know about that but I know you
could play a couple more for sure but
what goes fairly
your legs
but he doesn't really use them that much
I mean hey no I look it I maybe he can I
don't I personally don't think so but
you know maybe you can he's in great
shape but usually your legs go first
and that was the case of me I mean I
could still you know throw it pretty
good after I was retired but just
getting around and moving and getting in
your drops where you need to be making
people miss getting out of the way that
becomes a problem if you man if you
can't get out of way it's really
dangerous if you had Dallas's offensive
line this year at your age how many
touchdown passes could you throw 60 at
least you don't you to say that we
should improve it you probably put it
thrown for 60 in a season with today's
rules um yeah there's a chance someone
might do it again yeah someone might do
that yeah I went the wreck 55 now right
Payton pains go to st. at 55 I think I
had 48 Brady has 51 right yeah so yeah
someone could do that how much
competition is there between you guys
when you hear Brady's what makes Brady
the greatest quarterback of all time uh
is it just Super Bowl I think it's I
think it's know his competitiveness his
consistency you know as many games are
they wanted to gather him in Belichick
it's real like you know it's the
continuity they have with the with the
head coach and a quarterback being
together they know they could build
around that you know each and every year
you know players come and go but you
have that consistency there that's why
they went all the time is he better than
you I'm gonna say no one's better than
me but I just uh you know hit my plane
at a seven super but you have to think
that way we like to think as a
quarterback you know I mean they're all
great I mean if you talk about Peyton
and Brady Aaron Rodgers and Montana
Elway all those guys I mean I for me too
it just to be mentioned with those guys
is pretty special but you never sit
around and talk about memories when
you're with Montana or Elway there's no
game that comes up or nob not not a lot
of football talk some but not a lot what
do you talk about
oh just family whatever whatever maybe
golf anything about all know wine
you talk about nutrition hell yes you
look in here though pretty looks pretty
good all right yeah he did you put any
weight on or you stayed the same and I
had put a little weight on anyway I'm
kind of like bouncing back and forth a
little bit okay but so you guys were
extremely helpful as you know what I was
trying to lose a loose one extra
enormous one that was you when I went on
video my video look is a huge success
and then Dan's been trying to get me to
do some you know SoulCycle spin class or
he's trying to get me to get some more
exercise going on top of the agenda so I
told him you can't have Mountain Dew and
Doritos as well as lunch right that's
exactly right you can exactly and you
know he took me a little slap on your
stuff I had like a veal parm sub on my
desk well he Angus I said go six inch
not a footlong first of all and then
second of all he had a bag of chips
between his legs and he was sneaking he
was hiding it and I go dude you you've
got a lot of juice a little better
problem is like you know as far as
portion control we like with the
Nutrisystem you got to follow the plan I
thought that look anything there says
this to someone you could really
consumers mother baguette but [ __ ] you
like a snack yeah look at the whole box
right there it's the cheese because it's
part of our turkey yeah
not possible but Monday after the Monday
after the Superbowl you can start back
over because that's the biggest diet day
for men give us the petrel rigorous diet
day for men Monday after the Super Bowl
decision day and there's a new program
it's called lean thirteen why do you
think it's called lean 13 number
thirteen yeah eaters number thirteen so
you can lose thirty pounds
ah one month so you could do I worked
out nicely with a uniform number and of
our accounts perfect what kind of
nutrient what kind of nutrition did you
do when you played um did you know
anyone right yeah it was through yeah I
tried to eat right but sometimes you go
off that we don't have the same you know
the same education it was when I came in
leagues they do now and you know with
the dolphins and other teams you know
they have nutritionists they have
special diets for everybody
I'm sure talk about Tom Brady I'm sure
he's on a special diet eats only certain
foods and
you know works out certain ways that's
why he's able to play as long as he's
played did you ever go through
concussion protocol they didn't have it
they didn't have it no but I had a
couple concussions in my in my career
not a lot a couple yeah but they didn't
have protocol
what would they ask you if I was okay
that's it you okay go back
why there is a not in life well there
was times when I said you know it would
be a little dizzy and a little fuzzy but
I said I could play with it and I did
yep all dan I did some research and I
found the Miami Dolphins concussion
protocol from the 80s when Dan got hurt
they would look at the backup
quarterback and look at the end that's a
good protocol actually I think that's in
place today - that's mean spirits they
looked at Donst rock and they go oh no
Marino you're good don't go in it that's
funny
who rang your bell though um sorry to
those Rufus Porter Ward's hit me was an
outside linebacker for Seattle seal you
remember these things
he hit me once and pretty much knocked
me out and then then it was a couple
that I had kind of in Indianapolis and I
can't remember who they were but oh yeah
well that's not good
no I could find out oh okay oh yeah yeah
yeah I could find I just not have to top
my head yeah I was wondering it's good
that you remembered Rufus ported the bad
news okay member the Nicole holt yeah I
remembered before the show's over do you
remember we look for draft profiles of
our guests if they played or they're
currently playing and we couldn't find
one for you draft profile yeah when
you're coming out of pit okay
like strengths and weaknesses we did
Travis Kelce yesterday where they said
not a great athlete like all these four
there he is oh so they so like the
combine puts it out yeah yeah we'll we
got a Josh Norman's coming up von Miller
those kind of guy von Miller's too small
and all those things now we do the wrong
yep all the i-team tracked down audio
what was said about Dan Marino on draft
day and it wasn't all positive all right
play that too it is that was
Commissioner Pete Rozelle just to revise
to minute and a half of all as you made
the selection his announcement for the
selection of Danny
I don't number one I don't know who is
going to work with them down there who
is where is the great quarterback
coaching famous offers an orange party
great defensive coach I don't see where
he's going to get to straight to the
coaching that's going to overcome the
problem ginger I mean strictly look at
that long-range rejection down the line
and I think they need help another
directions maybe their comfort and what
they wanted wasn't there in the house
early on he would H Paul Zimmerman Paul
Zimmerman craft coverage and uh all
spent a lot of time covering the NFL all
the nice guy yes yeah didn't think you
were I mean yeah you're going to get
different opinions from different people
I mean I felt like I was one of the best
players in the draft that's just how you
feel that's how I felt but beyond that
obviously a lot of people didn't feel
that way but I'm glad Don Shula felt
that way when you could when was your
moment where you go okay welcome to the
NFL a good or bad right yeah yeah when I
went into mini camp you know when I went
down from mini camp after the draft and
walked into office and got to meet coach
Shula and like okay now this is it I
mean I'm here I'm gonna you know be a
quarterback on the Miami Dolphins and
and it was that was pretty exciting and
you were 13 in college as well yes yeah
like they're really cool too
actually I think I told you this but my
dad used to make me work when we have
baseball game or baseball team he
coached it right and other dads will
probably let their kid pick the number
first and he wouldn't to whatever's left
over is yours and it always kept up
being 13 so I was like okay I'm going to
make 13 my number and I'm you know
picking 13 in high school and in Ward
ever since would you ever do a reality
why they're doing the lean 13 you can
like the fighting it on not your system
I've gotten another hitter see that how
about that that's good then yeah but um
what were we talking about
how's everything else good everything's
great yeah really good housewife life's
good life's good kids are good yeah
whichever coach want to be in the front
office why I knew working on with the
Dolphins
yeah well involved are you with pretty
involved with you know with the team
going to practices I've been doing some
stuff with the draft in the Columbia and
yeah for the last couple years okay yeah
it's Tannehill a long
term solution there no doubt he's he's
really took taking a big jump I think
with you know Adam gates a new coach
it's a shame because you know he played
so well this year to get us into the
playoffs and he gets hurt yeah and he
can't you know can't play in a playoff
game but uh you know he had a great
attitude he's been he's been a great
player for us really yes but no doubts
in your mind no going forward no what if
Matt Ryan wins the Super Bowl what's it
do
that's awesome was great for him because
he's still a young guy and you can go
back to more Super Bowls uh what to do
it just say I could you know I Matt Ryan
Sunday night the wins walks off the
field saying I'm a Super Bowl champion
you know there's a lot of guys that
played including myself that never been
able to say that and really at the end
of the day that's really what you wanted
the quarter they would say you know I'm
a quarterback that won a Super Bowl and
know what that feeling is like how many
times did you re watch your Super Bowl I
never watched it once it's done it's
done when it was done yeah that I never
went back to watch person not even I
haven't watched not even curious of
sometimes I'm curious looking but now it
doesn't matter so I don't but I didn't
right after that I kind of put in my
mind I'm just going to go forward and
not worry about what happened in that
game so it'd be cool to have you in
Montana watch it together yeah be pretty
cool for him I mean come on yeah that's
alright well you know it'd be cool to
just see that honest reaction there I
know how it ends Ben
like I do it doesn't end well I
understand that but I it would be it
would be cool to see that yeah okay I
won't hold my breath for that that was
my next 34 34 ESPN a documentary on
having two great quarterbacks didn't
want to it's not a bad idea yeah during
the commercial break after another
Nutrisystem plugged by you okay would
you would you help us with just one of
your famous calls and a throat with
marine or a throat of McLovin yes yeah
yeah you will so which famous call you
want like a play well yeah and then the
when you have - that when you have the
oh yeah it's the greatest of all time
okay
yeah so we'll do that so give me one
more pitch for a Nutrisystem you can
help me with that okay oh because I got
all the information right here yeah try
the new Nutrisystem link 13 you know how
they came up with 13 yes my numbers oh
that's right yeah and your team powder
in a month yeah
on Monday is the biggest men's diet day
the day after the Super Bowl
you got that they have turbo shakes
they're pretty they got probiotics that
uh bust the belly blue that's awesome
and I'm saying this to everybody here
not just you know I understand I lost
like 25 pounds with distresses and I
look nice and slender for my kids one
perfect you perfect join Dan Marino and
get back in the game visit Nutrisystem
calm or new to systems the Twitter or
Facebook page for more information over
the man you're the mail always great to
see Dan Marino number 13 the Dan Patrick
show weekday morning on audience
[Music]